coming up next I think the Mother Day
woman is selfish mother day woman it
lacks accountability for motherly woman
hates men I don't like the fact that
you're back there a delusional
narcissistic self-entitled feminist who
shits on men for her poor choices but
sometimes you not feel like sometimes
some women are behaving the way they are
because men are not actually being
traditional men anymore who creates
those men that you're talking about
thanks women right so that's your answer
though women can't raise men so now you
raise that man that you talk about that
you don't like but then it's man's fault
but then you have the choice of who to
let in but then it's still a man's fault
how do you expect to have a traditional
man if you're trying to break every rule
of a traditional woman now you saw a
[__] you're coming to me like I want a
high value man it's like who the [__]
you think you are what it simply meant
increase of value over time whilst women
decrease in value whoa a traditional
woman is pure it's a virgin so so by
that definition no you can't become a
traditional woman I feel like being
traditional is boring like as women I
feel like we're constantly being told
how to be all the time what is a mod
Modern Woman and so start there go
around and then yeah I would say that
Modern Woman is
a woman that wants to have her cake and
eat it personally I think
um why do you think that
who me yeah
um because I noticed that whenever
there's like these debates and stuff
they pick all the
things that they want that um benefits
them and then when the coins on the
other side and you've got to the
benefits of a man of what like rolls at
the man play the women all of a sudden
have an argument against it and it's
like
you're never consistent with your
arguments it's like it keeps changing
it's changing bits from each
no because I was thinking I saw this
funny meme where it's like it showed
like the most blue haired like pink
feminist right she's like raging out in
the streets but the second she's in a
burning building she's like oh the
innocent woman who needs the man to help
her because like that's what she's
precise I was like yeah it's so funny
um I think a modern day woman is someone
who
doesn't necessarily who takes on roles
that is maybe for a man but
is but most of the time is due to
circumstances you know a lot of the time
it's due to circumstances I don't think
any woman actually wants to be a modern
day woman agreed yeah interesting yeah
interesting circumstances yeah
I think it's hard to say but I think for
me a modern day woman is someone who
wants to do what they want when they
want and doesn't want to feel guilty for
it I think that's fair
[Music]
I think a Monday woman is a woman who
has the freedom to choose
to
um
to indulge or go down roots that maybe
weren't available to her before
[Music]
um but I
I think I think a shift happens when her
priorities change but then sometimes
you know actions have consequences and I
think sometimes they're not always aware
of what those consequences are
I feel like you want to talk about
something specific this is General this
is just general General the warm-up
right now oh um a modern day woman for
me is a woman that works hard
but
in her working hard it may give her a
sense of entitlement
and a modern day woman may not even
necessarily be a woman
[Laughter]
I agree with Paris I think a modern day
woman is somebody who
um wants to have her cake and eat it I
think she's extremely lost
um and Confused in what she wants I
think only when it benefits her as she
because
we want to work but then at the same
time we don't want to work we want
somebody to look after us yeah that's
why I said it's due to circumstances not
always not always circumstance I would
say experience more than circumstances I
think a lot of modern day women
um base their beliefs on what's happened
in the past that has nothing to do with
them
oh other people's yeah yeah yeah but
that's life anyway everyone on Instagram
bases their beliefs on other people's
problems exactly I think as well we're
in like an era now which really
conflicting information about what a
woman's meant to like be yeah we've got
certain uh role models and like the
entertainment industry that are pushing
us whole like
um this word liberating lifestyle yeah
like you can do what you want and
they're not talking about the
consequences of it
um and then you've got like maybe like
your grandparents era where they're
teaching you all Traditional Values so
it's a big it's very confusing I think
if you're stuck between that it's like
you're almost like what what do I follow
this is what everyone in the world but
outside of my family home is telling me
and then if I look at
like traditionally what's happening it's
completely different so but those um
those women that sing all those songs
and everything they don't practice what
they preach oh yeah I know so true but
in terms of like the videos and stuff
and and what they're wearing and
everything hanging out like
they're doing that that's not the trip
for me personally I don't even know as a
celebrity quote unquote you have to also
be realistic that you take on that
responsibility or that knowledge that
you do influence people but I feel like
as an individual you shouldn't let those
people influence you you should have a
mind of your own yeah but I think that's
so gone I was gonna say I think that's
that's a bit of the double standard that
you want to be in the Limelight and with
that comes the responsibility to
influence yeah but then you don't want
to be held responsible for True You're
influence true yeah so and also where
women are of an age of Olden age so I
think that's easier for us to say but if
you're a younger girl like say 12 13
listen yeah to this and growing up with
this this is this is all you know yeah
but the likes of some of those girls who
put those songs out they don't let their
kids listen to it yeah so as a parent
I'm a parent I wouldn't let my children
like for instance my children don't
watch TV during the week I control what
they do and how often they watch it
that's good and there definitely is an
element of control but still but there's
only so much control you can have your
parents and I know that when my child my
child goes to school yeah
have you ever have you ever thought
about like homeschooling because you
can't yeah oh my God yes because I I've
always thought that like the schools are
so bad and where I'm from Chicago they
took away grades
they took away yeah they took away
grades recently didn't just parcel fell
I don't know my mom just told me they
took away grades but Chicago's Chicago
is known for having like [__] schools
like that's what we're and I'm like with
the this in the schools I'm like I
almost don't even want I don't agree
yeah and the thing is you don't know
what they're teaching your kids at
school you know or like how they're
treating your younger girl I was like at
this Leisure Center and I saw um they
were like shuffling in a bunch of like
five and six-year-olds and the way they
spoke to these kids was like so
atrocious I was like oh my God if their
parents were here like if I was their
parent I'd be like don't speak to my kid
like that
you know I wish I had the time to
homeschool but as a modern day woman
yeah I have to work I'll be honest
though even if I was like a traditional
I know what my skill sets are and I
don't think teaching is one of it so I
wouldn't deceive to think I would be
good at teaching I definitely couldn't
do math yes
sir I thought when there's such a small
that young age everything is learning
you know like even a trip to the grocery
shop yeah you're teaching them how to be
like if there's a line to teach them how
to be patient yeah yeah yeah
um even confidence building like okay
you pay for it there's so much learning
in everything just that's true we are
conditioned to think learning is in the
classroom just yeah there's so much more
good yeah there's like a thing called
World schooling
um I don't really know much about it but
I guess you just take your kid out into
the world and you're like is the world
learn yeah
we all had to start somewhere so there
was the world had to have been a
classroom at one point yes yes what do
you think Eddie what's a modern day
woman yeah
I think the modern day woman is selfish
I think a motherly woman like you said
once have a cake and eat it Mother Day
woman it lacks accountability what
motherly woman hates men I don't know I
said Eddie you're getting quite
comfortable back there yeah I don't like
the fact that you're back there come do
me son I want to be looking at you
exactly yes say it with your chest Eddie
yes but no yeah I just think I'm not a
woman is the things I mentioned um quite
problematic
um the main source of the problem to
modern day relationships oh my God
a delusional narcissistic self-entitled
feminist who shits on men for her poor
choices and she was so happy when she
said
you know I was practicing in my dressing
room because everyone came to get ready
I was already ready
sorry what were you gonna say
I know he's gonna get at me but
sometimes do you not feel like sometimes
some women are behaving the way they are
because men are not actually being
traditional men anymore oh my God yeah
yeah preach I think that's part of it
not in a I'm not saying in a negative
way that oh like you're not a man but I
feel like you you know how you said on
you said on the live show that you know
you guys we should be thankful to you
people because you guys have given us
the opportunities like we have right but
do you feel like you guys have even
managed us let's say what you're saying
is true but do you feel like you guys
have managed us as the men you're meant
to be
let me ask them one question who creates
those men that you're talking about
facts women right so that's your answer
there because the thing is right you're
saying about oh men being traditional
men
but but here's the thing though right if
you tomorrow if every woman in the west
was like you know what let's take sex
for example you know what I'm not having
sex with you unless we're in a committed
relationship every man would start or
would start acting correctly no I agree
with you so so in regards to okay what
is the minimum standard that a man has
to bring in order to get a woman
as women you all set the rules
I did say that men conform to the stand
is that female set exactly so if your
standards are low you're just playing
into our biological imperative we just
want to have sex and keep it moving if
you don't control how you um demand sex
then men don't have to do that so the
the problem with Society now is that
women want this oh I'm a mother woman I
can do what I like I can sleep with as
many men as a man can sleep with women
what is that do you end up pregnant the
man doesn't want to stay around the man
leaves for whatever reason then you're
raising a single parent you're raising a
child by yourself you put your kid at
every statistical disadvantage by
raising them by himself plus to put it
simply women can't raise men so now you
raise that man that you talk about that
you don't like but then it's man's fault
but then you had the choice of who to
let in but then it's still a man's fault
and thing is there's nothing wrong with
making those decisions like that like we
live in a free Society right part of
being a modern woman is being able to
choose what road you want to go down
yeah but then if you Cho if you go down
the modern the modern path don't ask for
a traditional man yeah I was going to
say how do you expect to have a
traditional man if you're trying to
break every rule of a traditional woman
exactly yeah well and that's a other
thing is like I'll always hear like
there's this book called why men love
[__] and like girls read it yeah
yeah girls girls girls read it and they
try to like inflate their value because
they'll like they'll sleep around or get
in a certain position or whatever and
then they'll say oh if you just raise
your standards but you can't like sell a
used Honda Civic at BMW prices the men
aren't stupid
you love that line
I don't know much about cars I had a
Honda Civic
Germany girls falling out in this little
[__] yeah but this but I that you saw a
[__] you're coming to me like I want a
high value man it's like who the [__]
you think you are yeah but I also think
that there are some men there are there
are some men that are spoiling the
market because it's giving this with
these women that are half like are naked
look good yeah you're giving them this
entitlement because you're giving them
the attention you're giving them the
money you're paying for their bills
you're paying for this so the next guy
they meet they're gonna want that
standard as well and they think they're
entitled to it because that's what's
been given to them for however many
times that's your own individual lack of
self-awareness because and a problem
with a lot of women now is that you
forget that men are dogs so you might
have a guy who's like a 10 who sleeps
with a girl that's like a three and now
you think you're a 10 because you slept
for 10. no I'm talking about the girls
that are 10.
I'm talking about the girls that you may
not want to marry but you'd class it as
a test I'll be honest the girls the
girls that are 10 are getting married
they're getting married 100 they're
getting married okay tens in terms of uh
the overall package yeah oh you're
talking about that that's what I'm
saying so okay are you talking about
that Instagram girl the girls the girls
that are Terrance but not wifey they'll
find a simp yeah that's true but what
yeah because because I do think that men
say oh yeah you know you're gonna get
banged but you're not gonna get married
not every modern woman that wants to get
married so you banging them and giving
them what they want is actually all
they're after so that's what I'm saying
in terms of just repeating that cycle I
don't think that's completely correct
because the majority of women still want
to get married and have kids
okay yeah because they'll say like I
don't need a man and then but I want a
man and so I'll say okay what type of
guy with you would you want and a lot of
times they'll start with saying oh I
don't want to get married and then when
they describe the guy that they want I
say okay so if that guy was interested
in marrying you would you want to get
married and they say yes and so it's
like the problem is the guys they want
just don't want to marry them because I
thought part of the multi-day woman was
that they're more courage or even the
more they don't really want to have
children and get married it was that
they want to have children get married
but they don't want it to hinder
anything from a statistical standpoint
yeah women by and large still want the
traditional family unit yeah yeah so I
literally searched this stuff up like
it's something like 60 60 70 of women
still want to get married okay but
basically you want to get married on
your own terms yeah I think I think what
I think what's become more of the the
normative culture for a lot of modern
women is that they use the years up to
the age of 30 to pursue their career
heavily and then they get to 30 and they
realize you know and it's a real thing
you know biological clock and go oh well
if I'm gonna have kids I kind of need to
start planning for it now yeah and then
and what happens is they start
prioritizing having the family and stuff
which is fair enough but then they start
asking for the different kind of man so
what they were asking for before was the
attractive guy that all the other girls
wants maybe the rappers whatever the hot
guy or this it's all good looking all
this right and then they get to you know
30 30s or whatever and they're like yo
that guy was fun but he wasn't gonna be
commitment away I just want a nice guy I
just want a nice guy I do the same thing
[Music]
can you see
men do the same thing and as they get
older they then start um making better
choices in the women that they're
sleeping with and who they would like to
have as a wife
but there's a but there's a difference
though for men right the game is
different for men because if a guy is
progressing in himself in his life in
his career in his steps right him
getting older right he can he has the
option to choose the girl that he was
just going to fool around with or to
choose the more if he's looking through
like a family traditional sense the
poetically also has that optionality
simply meant increase of value over time
whilst women decrease in value over time
whoa
yeah that's great I agree
can I just ask can uh a modern day woman
turn back to into a traditional woman
she can be a traditional she can be a
traditional woman in practice but in
terms of in
I think there are some I think there are
some things that
a traditional woman moves a certain way
in when she's young that's going to
benefit her when she's older a
traditional woman is pure as a virgin so
but by that definition no you can't
become a traditional woman I think you'd
be traditional in practice like as in
not even one oh my God so wait you are
not indeed a traditionally wow
if you look at it if you know if you
look at the body counts from before the
60s when
um birth control was introduced it was
like one two like the majority of women
only had one maybe two lifetime Partners
before the 60s
Dear God
but so there's no way you can deem a
woman
um a traditional woman if she's had sex
I no no I wouldn't say that with her
husband
I'm just saying okay if we're talking
percentage rise right let's say you take
the average girl who she played the
field right and then when she gets older
she wants a man that starts moving in a
traditional way right so you can be okay
she's like 60 of a traditional woman and
they take another woman who maybe she's
been like that since day dot okay she's
90 in terms of how traditional she is so
you can move in a traditional way I'm
just not like oh wait for me this way
that's that but there is but answer the
question what is a traditional woman
yeah I am confused I would say it's like
it's a woman that's pure she's youthful
um and if she's not youthful she's
married so like you can have a
traditional woman that's married if
she's older
um she has to like prioritize the family
above all else so I would say like she's
the type of girl that has like Kevin
Samuels would say do you have a cookbook
and it's true like what how do you how
do you Foster tradition in your in your
home but I I don't think you can be a
traditional woman unless you're either
married or a virgin I feel like being
traditional is boring like as women I
feel like we're constantly being told
how to be all the time like you have to
be like this
this is you're a feminist
are you a feminine yeah I guess so like
okay okay I'm not on any one side I'm
just lit I think I'm here today to just
learn right so do you now think because
being um what what is boring in being a
traditional
woman like the whole idea of like
staying at home and cooking and like
looking after the kids like
do you think you only think that way
because you're exposed to so much more
you know there's more that you can do
okay yes like that's why I said sorry so
can I ask
the women here do you classify yourself
as a modern or a traditional woman I
think I couldn't trust between both I
think most everyone does both yeah like
I would love to be a traditional woman
but I don't have that option because
maybe I've made decisions or I've gone
through certain things in life that now
I may be deemed by the likes of you guys
I'm no longer traditional I feel like
you can go through periods as well like
when you're younger you might be like
non-traditional and as you get older you
start to learn okay maybe there's some
value in being a business
decrease in value yeah like the whole
point is like girls want to sleep around
in their 20s and then at 30 run to a man
and like but you've lost the things you
that men value by the time you're 30
you're no longer pure you're no longer
youthful and so men are kind of tired of
it because what happens is they'll date
the bad boys the rappers whatever in
their 20s and then they hit 30. one guy
thinks like this is his lucky ticket
this girl's super into him but she just
wants kids and like she really feels
like she settles for him she gets the
kids and then half the time leaves yeah
can I be can I ask a lady is a question
in the room do you want
a traditional man when I say traditional
man I mean the kind because if it
depends how far back you want to go but
we're talking like he tells you it's his
rules in his house
right so it's kind of like you utterly
submit to him right yeah he's paying the
bills he's protecting all of those
things but like there are pros of being
traditional yeah but there's the other
side of the coin that you have to accept
as well so I guess I'm asking do you
want do you guys want a traditional are
you looking at me so if I'm if I'm
honest if I'm honest I think I could
have been with that when I was younger
so when I when I if my ex-husband if he
treated me like that he would have got
he we would be living like that and it
would have been fine because we got
married young and everything and that's
all I knew but now that um I've had to
grind I've had to go through struggles
and stuff I've had to put myself in
certain situations it will it will take
a lot for me to decide to get into that
I think I'd want a mixture yeah like my
husband I think he is a mixture in terms
of obviously his his word is final but
he lets me do what I want to do there's
no restriction on that on on me so I
still think that's traditional okay I
don't think restriction is necessarily
like if your husband said
um like say say they wanted to go
somewhere and he said no I don't think
you should go would you say
and if it was like if he said babe like
because he's he's in the security world
so he's one as when he says risk I sit
down
and this is what I say sometimes when
montoyasi we
if I call my turkey and she's got a man
I say we're going out she says I'm not
coming I'll be like cool or even if she
and this is why it's when some people
say that um you shouldn't be friends who
with people who are single because
they're bad influence and I don't
believe that because you see my married
friends they can never call me to tell
me that we're going to the club school
I'm going to no club with you what are
you doing there yeah you're an exception
though no but there's a lot of girls
that are like most girls want their
friends to be single so they this one
this is why I always do anything wrong
with asking a single friend to go
because never take advice from women
because a girl will want to put you in
the same situation she's in how many
girls will get his friends will get a
man and they'll be like oh he's taking
you away from me
[Music]
I agree with you I agree with you
because I I mean I think girls have fomo
like naturally like if if most girls if
you see all your friends are going to
something you're going to want to go and
if your dude doesn't want you to go like
I've seen it cause problems if I am
happy in my marriage
but in any relationship there's going to
be times where you're not yeah but
I'm sorry I keep interrupting sorry I'm
sorry no but I'm saying so like in any
relationship there's going to be times
when you're not and I think sometimes
like when the rubber hits the road like
the single friends aren't the best
influence and I'm not saying all the
time but I'd say by and large you
wouldn't say most women are probably bad
influences on their on their married
friends I would never tell my friend to
leave her husband or do anything that
will impact her marriage if she's doing
something that's wrong I'm gonna tell it
it's regardless I'm single or not
because
I think as you get older and you get
exposed maybe because we're in the
podcast world and you have different
discussions you realize that look
everybody is here for their individual
things like we didn't come into this
world together and we're definitely not
going to leave together so you have to
respect if you love your friend that
much you will Embrace and make sure what
they've got going on is as successful as
possible if you mean that you're the
exception in it
I genuinely think you are an exception I
feel like I think you'll like that
though no no no no yeah when we when I'm
going through my issues and whatever is
to ride it out yeah I know but there's
some like that's like talking to you
one-on-one okay your personal situation
yeah I'm saying like for example as a
single person if my married friend was
having issues I'd like come out with me
like let's go do something like let's go
to the club to get your mind over things
but subconsciously it's it's not a good
influence yeah yeah so but you would be
the same person that after after she's
had the fun you'll be the same person to
sit her done until Where She Went Wrong
I've seen you do it so many I think a
big part of it like I I agree I think I
think if a woman feels that the man that
she is with is the top man in the sub
she feels like she won with him right
then I think she's like you know what
now I don't feel like I need to I don't
feel like I'm missing out because I knew
how hard it was to find a man like him
but I think if a girl is or if a woman
is with a man that she feels like she
settled for then she can almost see the
opportunity of going out is still being
able to fish yeah do you have a reason
for going out then going out and was
fine
just go out just to enjoy yourself but I
feel women settled why why do you think
women will go to clubs do women do women
settle or do they get what they can get
like to me that's the same dude yeah but
I'm saying like I'm not getting what I
want yeah getting what I can get so it's
a settled right but I wouldn't say
you're settling if you okay if you go to
the store and you're worth five dollars
and you're and you're bought for five
dollars you might you might have like
you know seen seen a ten dollar product
imagine if you're gonna go to UNI and
you're like oh this is no disrespect
anyone here but it's like oh um I'm
going to reading uni now I'm setting him
for ready and I want to go to Oxford
it's like okay well did you get into
Oxford no well then you didn't settle
for anything that was the best choice
for you because we're all selfish by
Design and this is what happens when the
man that's a 10 bangs are Guild sr3 then
you call us deluded because we think we
can get a man that's a 10.
but it's because like women we're not
honest with each other like you you know
when your friend's sleeping out of her
League you know damn well but nobody
tells you you know what is that it's not
I don't think it's the sleeping with the
10 and whatever I feel like we've we've
asked girls sometimes we get a little
bit carried away and we're not realistic
you may be sleeping with a guy who's a
10 but is he treating you like a 10
treating you like a 10 and sleeping with
you like a 10 or three or whatever you
are is two different things how they
treat you is another is a whole nother
ball game yeah I think women kind of
like men that don't treat them well
though
I'm just I'm just saying like if if we
really hated toxic men why do we all
have a toxic ex because we're
traumatized
yeah but like but why would you date him
like I mean as a like as you're living
out your trauma
yeah this is the accountability thing oh
my God you just made it obvious it's
like
this guy gave me trouble you picked him
no no I'm not talking about men see I'm
not even talking about men I'm talking
about like experiences in your life like
with your parents you know like we are
literally walking trauma bombs wouldn't
you say it's just an excuse for poor
decisions yeah no I wouldn't okay what
would you call it
I would say we're just walking trauma
bombs and we have to do the work to heal
ourselves so that we don't repeat the
patterns right the thing is I always say
to my friends look if you're in a toxic
relationship right and you and you
experience the same thing right another
guy comes along again toxic relationship
who's the common denominator in this
situation you so you're the problem so
fix yourself and then go get the thing
you want or maybe but maybe she's toxic
exactly
but that's what I'm saying like a lot of
times girls will say oh like
like they blame it on the guys like oh
the guys are toxic and or they'll say
they'll say something like oh it's my
ability to pick but it's like
um is it your ability to pick or are you
toxic do you have toxic traits this is
why I'm saying yeah a lot of women are
toxic I don't think most girls even
saying that to their friends and this is
what I mean about don't take advice from
women because your girl will see a girl
will do something in a relationship well
there's always two sides to the story
and then she'll go to a girl and say
look he's doing this that in the third
ignoring everything that she's doing and
another friend will say well you know
men are like this and blah blah blah
blah blah where does she take
accountability where does she have the
opportunity to help and say let me
develop from this situation and make
better decisions in the future
your friends or your firm your behavior
I'm the exception no no but also like
you have to again you have to look at
your cycle right like if you're toxic
heavily toxic right the likelihood of
your best friend being toxic is quite
High how many people would admit the
genuinely toxic yeah I think I think it
starts from I don't know I I personally
think it starts from like having
children being a mother because I've got
a daughter and a son and whenever my
daughter comes to me and says oh Ezra
did this to me I said okay what did you
you do and then I find out she's done a
list of things and I have to hold her
accountable for it I don't because
sometimes especially being the girl you
get lit off with a lot of things 100 and
it starts from there I think younger
sisters yeah exactly yeah
Mom I don't know about that shots my
name straight away he's like I didn't
even I'm leaving
I'm not even in the house I feel like
this now this is a controversial thing
but I feel like moms love their sons
more yeah but you can say dads love
their daughters more so both are getting
loved yeah because it's quite I'm my
mom's favorite really I don't know why I
think it's I think it's quite common
because the whole thing of like so the
whole thing of okay it takes a father to
raise a man and takes a mother to raise
a woman right so when it and because
because men women we operate differently
right I will never understand what it
means to move in this world as a woman
you'll never understand we we play by
different rules so a lot of the time in
a lot of families the mother is the
disciplinary for the daughter and the
father is disciplinary for the for the
the sun it's like back in the day you
know be like the father would be like to
the son of King to go out there you need
to slay the snake or the rabbit and come
back and if he doesn't do it this the
father beats him but the mum's like come
here baby you did well like I'm proud of
you equally the mother to to the
daughter would be like okay you need to
fill these basket of berries right and
maybe she fills one basket not two the
father's like oh my little girl you got
a basket of berries but the mother's
like no this isn't good enough because
if you're going to be the wife of the
home you need to be able to do this so I
think often you know you say daddy's
little girl do you know what I mean
there's more mommy's boys daddy's little
girls because a lot of people are single
parents yeah and there's no daddy in the
picture
yeah no they don't they don't they don't
women waste very Sims but a caveat to
that anyway wait say that again
I can like tell in a guy's voice if he
didn't have a mom in the home I don't
know how to describe it I'm sorry sorry
no no I'm serious like like you can just
tell in the way they interact with you
it's it's really weird I don't know what
would you say is like more feminine or
like slightly yeah or it's like they
almost like
it's almost okay I feel like when you
look at a kid that's a boy right it's
like they're they're naturally the
things men should be like they speak
their mind they like play they're like
like all that stuff and it's like you
see that 22 years later you can just see
they've been like feminized and it's
like they're almost like programmed to
think differently because like women
raise them or telling them what to say
and what to think
that's the same sorry but you said it's
the same with if uh the father was in
the life but it's not in the home
do you still see that
um it depends I think like if it's 50 50
custody potentially but if the mom like
I know a couple where like I can't tell
but they're usually older right you know
what I'm saying but in a caveat to that
as well as that when it comes to
single-parent Homes single parent homes
with a father is the single parent the
kids tend to turn out better than when
the the mother is a single parent
do you know why that is I don't know why
that is
it's after the age of like women raise
better kids up to the age of like seven
where men raise better kids after and
it's because
um I mean they think it's because men
are more consistent where women are more
emotional so it's like confusing for a
kid like what's right what's wrong when
mom's on her period once a month and
like today like this is really wrong but
last week is kind of wrong you know
um and the other thing is that men are
better with money financially so yeah uh
no I mean majority the majority like
like women make 70 to 80 percent
consumer buying decisions we also spend
more even though we make less okay
I believe that I agree and so like
yeah on Sheen okay like she needs to
chill out
so I have a question for the women
how much does your submission cost
oh what do you mean like okay so when I
I use this example when I say submission
so he says babe trust me quit your job
no
do you think if I just picked someone to
spend the rest of my life with okay and
I've I've gained that much trust for
them I think I would be able to do it
fifteen thousand pounds a year is what
do you mean
okay 20 000 pounds a year I don't think
it's even there's there's a that means
there is a price there is a price for me
like
me like emotional
okay so emotional security but he earns
30k
that's not true though um women leave 70
to 80 percent of the time because 90 of
their college educated like men really
don't leave because I mean we're
literally paid to leave
okay 50 000 pounds
sixty thousand pounds right so I can't
work at all like can I have a little
side Hustle No no no that's not the
point like you you I didn't tell you
what he's gonna have you do maybe you
work for him I don't know he just okay
he just says quit your job trust me okay
I think fifty thousand I have a plan I
think fifty thousand fifty thousand yeah
so if it guys make it this is me
this is a lot of trust here dead number
four thousand four thousand okay
that's true
I'll say I'll say 50. I think I will
feel safe enough to like what what
percent of men do you think make fifty
thousand
like six percent no it's probably higher
it's not high but it's hiding there it
must be like 50. actually I don't I
would have thought it would be quite
fairly High I think for the higher end
in the UK is seven years the average
income in the UK I think is between 24
and 28 000 a year that's the average so
40 of Mary 10 make about 70k yeah and
that's the higher end so that's that
would be higher value in yeah so maybe
it's like 15 percent
it says six percent of the UK population
earn more than fifty thousand dollars oh
my God
did you know that stuff you were like
six percent I didn't
foreign
but it's a six percent of the UK
population earn more than 50 000 pounds
a year it only matter in London because
like five percent of that is in London
yes
let me do London so everyone go around
and say what your submission costs I'm
gonna look it up oh my God be honest as
well
um
[Music]
he will need to earn
a hundred and something okay and and I
know it sounds like a wild number but
the only reason why I'm saying that is
I'm thinking about what I know costs are
right now
and I'm thinking if he could earn that
and even whatever he's got planned
doesn't necessarily go to plan I know
we're still okay
so yeah okay what do you think
um I think for me like you would have to
earn I don't know like probably like
over 100k like and I would have to get
money sent to my bank account like every
month like I would have to be getting
paid like I know you're asking questions
so if he gave you 500 pounds a month 500
okay so I had this conversation with
someone right he's paying for everything
okay you have no bills okay you have no
nothing your phone bill every
electricity everything and he gives you
500 pounds to spend on whatever you want
every month is that enough how much is
he making that's not your business yes
but your bills are paid like so what you
used to spend on by yourself yeah bills
used to you don't need to pay for that
anymore you've now got 500 pounds to do
your nails anything you want to do 500
pounds is that okay
I mean if that's all he can give that's
all he chosen to give he's not but we
can he's just chosen to give you 500.
okay that I have so many questions but I
mean like
it's black and white that's the minimum
like sorry if that's like all he can
give then of course like I'm more than
happy I don't know because I'm swimming
with our words that's it's not about
whether it's all he can give he has
chosen to give you 500 all your bills
are paid it's not about chosen or all he
can afford it's not about what he can
afford he said you are getting 500
pounds
wouldn't you say that's nice of him that
is nice of him you're not happy about it
but like I want to know more context
about the situation
sorry can I ask a follow-up on that yeah
the whole thing of you whether you're
satisfied at 500 pounds
if that was all he could give it sounds
like you'd be okay yeah if he could give
you 5 000 it sounds like you'd be pissed
um
but he chose a 500. I would like I
the thing is as well like I would look
at my own circumstances well like how
much do I actually need you know like do
I need more than 500 because if I do
then I would have to have well you don't
need you in terms of everything is
painful everything's paid this is just
this is what would you need it for this
is your play money this is
Monopoly money lashes Nails yeah I'll be
fine with 500 of course okay but why was
it so hard for you to because like
I don't know like for me I just feel
like if he's earning like a lot of money
and we're a partnership like we're
building
you know things together family together
a house together then why would he want
to limit me like I would like if if it
was the other way around I would always
give more I would always
just about to say like why do you you
part of you guys building a house
together and whatever has not got
anything to do with you financially your
part is keeping the home safe and secure
so so long if that's our agreement
between us then yeah but as soon as so
baby as soon as you stop working and
stuff
Financial was not part of your yo you
you are yeah true I'm saying so why is
it I just feel like us women
like I'm I as well I'm trying to unlearn
a lot of bad habits of and I think it's
because we've been given so much power
in terms of the jobs that we have access
to so sometimes the jobs we have we
bring that mentality home and how we
communicate with men and all of that you
have to remember they're paying you so
they deal with our [__] but a man
has chosen to marry you so I don't have
to deal with this even though I've asked
you to marry me I I decided to ask you I
didn't have to ask you the maddest thing
about that is that
you will go into work every day if even
though you hate your job and you won't
talk back to your boss yeah and in that
same scenario that we just painted where
your man's giving you free money Etc
you're still going to come back to your
man and try and cause trouble at home
that makes zero sense to me
in that and that's in that situation
my my
um one little thing that I would say is
that it's not the 500 that is an issue
for me it's
um
the trust I feel like the trust should
go both ways so for me for me you
capping me at 500 is kind of like one
I'm a dependent you don't really trust
your children with money like that so
you're it's almost like I'm a dependent
I'm a child
um and secondly
for me as I said I feel like if you just
if your card's just saying it's like
babe like do the shopping or whatever
you should trust me yeah as your wife
that I'm not going to be Reckless with
your money but it's for me I don't know
it maybe it's a me problem how it will
make me feel yes not necessarily that is
the cap that how it would make me feel
but also like you also don't you also
don't know why he's doing it yeah
like like saving for a house or
something but the whole point of
submission is like you trust her yeah
that's why Nations right yeah but that's
why I said it might be a main problem
that how how it makes me feel I don't
think it's a thing where the hell don't
disagree with what you're saying but I
think we're all very like intelligent
adults yeah we just quoted a stack that
women own two-thirds of Consumer Debt we
make all the money I think women are
children actually
that's controversial no really you're
just trying to find the best
well you have to expand on that one no
no no if we know the facts as to how
women make consumer decisions then again
and you trust your man doesn't it just
doesn't it make sense that you know if
left your own devices over time you'll
become frivolous with that money yeah
I think it may be different it may be
subjective because I handle all the
bills and stuff in my house no that I
pay for it but my husband I think I'm
better with in terms of
organization I don't know I don't think
I'm the exception I think that might be
a quality of a wife no I think like a
lot of girls are better at like
accounting yeah
we have like a whole spreadsheet you
know I mean we have the incomings and
I'm much more better with budgeting and
all that stuff yeah but I think men like
just don't make impulse decisions as
much yeah yeah like we'll see like a
cute outfit we'll be like buy it don't
even look at it yeah okay
um you um feeling that way about the 500
so if he had left you with his card
unlimited you probably will still spend
just that 500 anyway so is it not more I
might not I might not even spend the
time exactly the the the figure is not
the issue it's the it's the not trusting
me because to me what it says is that
you don't trust me that's what it says
it has like an underlying feeling of
like control so I might spend 100 I
might spend 50 years
not controlled well not for me well I
think I think like being feminine is
like giving up control is really hard
for most modern women yeah yeah like
because we're told to like we operate in
a masculine Society of like go out and
get it I disagree I think we operate in
a gynocentric society that puts women on
a pedestal and also bails them out of
every bad decision that we make ever and
tells us we're queens and perfect all
the time we are Queens
when you say in a mask in society as in
in order to succeed in society yeah you
have to manifest and grow the things
that are traditionally masculine because
that's what's going to get the results
yeah
oh
part of the issue is because this power
that we now have is new so we're now
learning things so for me if I had a
daughter and she was really successful
part of her her upbringing will also
know when to play that role when to take
power and when not to whereas back then
the parents didn't even the women didn't
have that power I don't think he said it
didn't no they didn't know to tell their
daughters or that we like I didn't learn
the things I know now from my mum
because my mum necessarily didn't become
the successful woman she was when I was
young as I got older so then when I
became successful and I realized I
understood what I really wanted and I
realized where the problem was coming
then I understood that you got a
different shape work and well I think
the question is is what the success look
like to you because to the traditional
woman successful success would look like
raising okay successful women now looks
like I want to make money as much money
success to me as a single woman is being
able to give myself the life I would
wanted if I was married but that's
because I'm single but success to me as
a married woman is being in a home where
my heart my husband I can carry him
literally on my head and he is like my
prize Jewel he's successful I rub his
back I support him mad in her DMS
no but that's why I'm saying no but
that's why I'm saying to you that some
of us women the way we behave is is also
it's just our circumstances I don't
wanna I don't want to go to work
so right sorry but I'm saying like it's
our choices okay so yeah well okay yeah
you can't say any girl in this room
couldn't be married at 21 22. yeah I got
mad at 23. yeah yeah yeah as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible